the origin of copyright law takes us
back to 1710 and Queen Anne the monarch
who had just overseen the unification of
England and Scotland into the then
brand-new Great Britain also on her busy
schedule was the statute of Anne the
very first copyright law
it gave authors control over who could
make copies of their books or build on
their work for a limited period of time
later a group of rebellious colonists
thought that the statute of Anne was a
good idea and so copy pasted it into
their own Constitution giving Congress
the power to promote the progress of
science and useful arts by securing for
limited times to authors the exclusive
right to their respective writings
basically copyright is a contract
between authors and society if you
promise to make more stuff we promise
not to copy it or build on it for 28
years here's an example from the modern
day let's say you're trying to be a
director and you're looking for a
project to get started Harry Potter is a
story you'd love to remake but since JK
Rowling published the Sorcerer's Stone
in the United States in 1998 it still
has copyright protection so you can't
use it instead you need to find
something from a long time ago for
example George Lucas released Star Wars
a new hope in 1977 that's more than 28
years ago so great get filming alas no
while Star Wars should have lost
copyright protection in 2005 it's
actually copyrighted until 95 years
after publication not 28 so you can't
use it unless Lucas lets you why does
his copyright lasts for ages well as
long as there has been copyright there
have been authors arguing that it's too
short and perhaps they're right house
poor guy like Luke is supposed to turn a
profit in the mere 28 years between 1977
and 2005 after all there was only the
theatrical release of the new hope and
the theatrical re-release in 1978 and
again in 1979 and 1981 and 1982 and then
there was the 1982 VHS and Betamax
releases the 1984 broadcast television
released a 1985 laserdisc released in
1989 widescreen laserdisc release the
1990 VHS re-released in 1992 widescreen
VHS release the 1993 laserdisc
re-release the 1995 VHS riri release the
1997 special edition theatrical release
han shot first you bastard
the 1997 VHS special edition released
from the 2004 DVD release and now you
dear filmmaker come along and want to
make your own version of Star Wars a new
hope for shame that's like stealing food
right out of George Lucas's mouth four
times Congress has agreed with authors
at the length of copyright is too short
to turn a profit and has so extended it
first in 1831
twenty-eight years - 42 years then again
in 1909 - 56 years in 1976 - the
lifetime of the author plus 50 years and
in 1998 - the lifetime of the author
Plus 70 years that's a great deal for
authors who have already made stuff but
does it really helps decide to get more
books in movies it's hard to imagine for
example that Edgar Rice Burroughs
started writing a princess of Mars and
Tarzan in 1911 because the copyright
laws had just been extended and would
not have done so otherwise or that JK
Rowling while living on benefits in
Scotland was busy doing the math and
wouldn't have written Harry Potter if
the copyright protection was just for
her whole life and not an additional 7
decades thereafter because exactly who
needs incentives after they're dead dead
is the point at which literally no
incentives in the whole universe can
compel you to write one more screenplay
because you're dead dead dead dead dead
dead if you're the kind of person who is
only motivated by plans that unravel
after your demise you're either
amazingly awesome or deranged but so
what so what if every kindergarteners
macaroni artwork is protected by
copyright for 175 years why does it
matter because the main beneficiaries of
copyright after death are not the
authors or society but companies
companies like Disney remember all the
old good Disney movies yeah all of them
came from works no longer under
copyright protection at the time the
whole of the Disney Empire and the
childhood magic that it produces only
exists because there was copyright free
work for Walt Disney you know the guy
who actually started the whole company
to rework an update but the corporate
Walt Disney was the big pusher of the
1998 life Plus 70 years copyright
extension it made sure that no one can
make a more popular version of their
movies in the same way they made a more
popular version of Alice in Wonderland
this near-infinite control subverts the
whole purpose of copyright which is to
promote the creation of more books and
movies not to give companies the power
to stop people making new creative works
based on the efforts of their long-dead
founders new directors and authors need
the freedom to take what came before and
remake and remix and they should be able
to use the creative material from their
own lifetimes to do so not just be
limited to the work of previous
generations at the end of the century
George Lucas wrought upon civilization a
new word and disappointment the
tremendous letdown that was the lazy
bland and soulless new trilogy George
Lucas was completely within his right to
make those movies into the sterile toy
marketing vehicles they were he owned
Darth Vader and could tell the origin
story as he wished but imagine for a
moment if copyright still worked his
first intended in 2011 the whole of the
original Star Wars trilogy all of its
artwork its Karen
it's music would have left copyright
protection and been available to
aspiring directors and writers to build
upon and make their own versions out
there would have been a treasure trove
of new Star Wars stories for fans to
enjoy but as long as the current
copyright laws remain as they are no
living person will ever get to tell the
Darth Vader story or a Harry Potter
story or a hobbit story or any other
story that matters to them that the
author or when they're dead their
company disagrees with
[Music]